[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Maya Kaczorowski.
MANJOT PAHWA: I'm Manjot.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And today we'll
be talking about
network security
controls for your containers.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
So today we'll be covering first
container network security 101.
How does that even--
how is it different
for you to secure
your container network
than for your
traditional VM network?
Container network
security controls-- so
how you can make sure that
your network resources are
accessed by authorized parties?
And we'll dive deep
into the controls that
are available for you on GKE.
And then visibility--
how you can
monitor the traffic that flows
between different containers
in your environment.
Lastly, we'll leave
some time for Q&A.
So container network
security 101--
first, how is securing
containers and container
networking different than VMs?
Well, containers have a
different surface of attack
than virtual machines do.
They are meant to
be smaller, meant
to reduce bloat images
that you deploy.
For networking,
what that means is
that a lot of the plugins
and things like that
should be smaller.
It's the same idea,
you're going to want
to reduce the amount of things
that you add to your container
images so you have fewer
chance of vulnerabilities
in those containers.
Service isolation--
containers and orchestrators
like Kubernetes have some
built-in ways for you
to isolate your
different services
and resources, including
storage, permission,
networking, et cetera.
One of those things
are firewalls and then
network policies.
Kubernetes has built-in
concepts to let
you have isolation
with firewalls
between different
containers in your network.
Permissioning-- access
control on network resources
and other resources
allow delegation
of administrative
functions without having
potential compromise
or other issues.
So you can have a
separation of duties
between who sets
up your containers
and your networking
versus who has
to use those containers
and that networking.
And lastly, lifecycle--
containers, on average,
have a very short lifespan.
Sysdif estimates that 95% of
containers live for less than a
week.
What that means from the
attacker point of view
is that it's harder for someone
to persist in your network.
But if they do persist
in your network,
and then you restart that
container or redeploy
that container, you might
not have any forensics to
as to what happened
after the fact.
This doesn't really
impact networking,
but might impact how you put
in place certain controls.
MANJOT PAHWA: So what are the
different surface of attacks
we need to be worried about?
The first one, as
Maya mentioned,
is network resources.
As an organization,
you might not
want critical network
resources like your lb rules,
your firewalls, your peerings,
to be under the control
of every single project admin.
You might want to have
them be under the control
or be set up by network
and security admins.
Second, private
addressing-- you might
want to ensure that your
entire deployment, including
your nodes, your
boards, et cetera are
within the secure
boundaries of your VPC.
Moreover, you might want
to ensure that your control
pane is also isolated
from unauthorized access
over the internet.
Third, service communication--
another thing to ensure around
the surface area of
attack can potentially
be service-to-service
communication.
So you might want
to ensure or control
the access of which
services can can
talk to which other
services through something
like network policy,
which enables
you to set up those rules.
Fourth, managed
services access--
when you're using a Kubernetes
or a GKE deployment,
chances are you're also using
a host of GCP-managed services,
like Container Registry, or
data Dataproc or BigQuery,
and several others.
Another thing to ensure, or
another surface area of attack
to cover, is the communication
between your GKE deployments
and your managed services.
So looking at network
security overall,
the image in front
of you will tell you
where all those pieces fit in.
So first and foremost,
your deployments
are within the secure
boundaries of a VPC network.
You have your private
clusters, which
have no public IPs on
the nodes, and which
can securely communicate
to other clusters over VPC
firewalls.
Moreover, you have VPC service
controls to control access
to other managed services
like Container Registry
and BigQuery.
On the L7
internet-facing side you
have Cloud Armor, an
Identity-Aware Proxy setup,
with your global load
balancer to control access
to your GKE deployments.
And you use master authorized
networks in your GKE clusters
to control unauthorized access
to your Kubernetes master.
Similarly, you
have network policy
if you drill down
within a single cluster
for a setup for
service-to-service
communication.
So let's talk about the network
security controls in detail.
The first thing we are going
to talk about is Shared VPC.
So I spoke about how,
as an organization,
you want to delegate
administrative responsibilities
to your project
admins, but you don't
want your critical network
resources to be dealt by them.
You want them to be under the
network and security admins.
Shared VPC enables
you to do that.
Private clusters help you
achieve network segmentation
by ensuring that your nodes are
within the secure boundaries
of your VPC and use
only RFC 1918 addresses.
And moreover, for
private clusters,
another thing you can
potentially put in place
is master authorized networks.
A master authorized
networks puts
in an IP whitelist on your
Kubernetes or GKE master
and ensures that it's blocked
from unauthorized access
over the internet.
Network policy helps you
segment microservices
by restricting which services
can talk which other services.
Now, let's talk in more
detail about each of those.
So I spoke briefly
about Shared VPC.
And Shared VPC is
what enables you
to map your organizational
topology to your network
topology.
So let's say you
have an infra team
and several apps teams
in your organization.
You want the apps
team project admins
to be able to create,
update, delete, and manage
those clusters seamlessly,
but you might not
want them to set up things
like org-level firewalls,
or you might not
want them to set up
lb rules, and a host
of other such things.
So in order to have
that model be present,
you can use Shared VPC.
So you put your infrastructure
project in your host project,
and you have a shared VPC
within that host project.
Within the shared VPC you add
a host of service projects
which actually have your
app-specific clusters.
This way you get security
and separation of rules,
your network and
security admins set up
the firewalls and not
the project admins,
and you get sharing
of common resources.
Because if, for example,
you have a pool of IP
addresses that you want to share
across that shared VPC network,
you can actually achieve that.
You get isolation
of data in workloads
by isolating the different
projects in the subnets.
And you also get more
granular billing,
because you can actually
separate out the projects.
So Shared VPC deep dive--
as I mentioned, there
is a host project,
and within the host project
there's a shared VPC network.
The shared VPC network
itself can be divided
into a bunch of subnets.
And then you give
your app projects
permissions over
a single subnet.
So you give them the
compute.network user permission
over a single subnet.
And this way, your app teams
can actually create, manage,
and delete clusters.
But if you want to
set up firewalls,
let's say, then you have
to go to the network admin.
So you talk to the
network admin and you
ask them to set up firewalls for
you in the Shared VPC network.
This way, you get, as I
mentioned earlier, separation
and isolation of
rules, while still
enabling you to share
common resources
throughout your organization.
Moving on to the
second one, which
is private deployments
with private clusters,
private clusters take your
nodes off the public internet
by removing all the public IPs.
We used to initially
required the public IPs
in order to communicate
with your GKE master.
But that is no longer a
requirement with advancements
in our peering capabilities.
So now for your
private clusters,
the communication between
your master and your nodes
is completely private
and within your VPC.
And moreover, if you create
a private cluster, by default
we enable master
authorized network,
which default denies all
unauthorized access to your
to your GKE master.
Private clusters
help you simplify
the scope of some of the
compliance requirements
that you might have
for your applications.
As I said about master
authorized networks,
by default, if you
create a private cluster,
we enable master
authorize network,
and we highly recommend using
master authorized network along
with your private cluster.
If you want to enable certain
IP ranges on your on-premises
to have access to
your GKE master,
you can set up a master
authorized network
with some certain site
or ranges that you want
to whitelist over your master.
This way you have
a private cluster,
and you block unauthorized
access, and you allow only
authorized IP
addresses to access it.
A brief note about shared VPC--
so you cannot move from a
non-shared VPC to a shared VPC.
You cannot update an existing
cluster in a non-shared VPC
model to a shared VPC model.
Similarly, you cannot update
a cluster that is not private
to become private.
But you can add master
authorized network
to an existing cluster.
So you might want to start off
with shared VPC model first
of all, then move on to
creating private clusters,
and then updating, removing
master authorized networks.
Looking deeper into how
to enable it in the UI,
you clearly see a
network security space
where you can enable
a private cluster.
And the moment you
enable a private cluster,
you see that we have enabled
master authorized network,
where it says "Access master
using the external IP address."
So you can actually
add all trace networks
right underneath it, if
you want to, over there.
Network policy-- so
I've already mentioned
how as you develop a
microservices architecture
for your applications,
you might want
to restrict which services can
doctor which other services.
Earlier, when in
VM-based architectures,
how services were
isolated were usually
with a firewall or
network layer firewall,
which was very typically a
physical device on the VM.
So a service was
isolated, let's say,
in a few VMs, which could only
talk to certain other VMs.
But that model doesn't work
when it comes to containers.
As Maya mentioned earlier,
the container lifecycle
is very short and
they're very dynamic.
So they keep on
coming and going.
So the newer way to
actually control or restrict
service-to-service communication
and set access controls
on which service can talk
to which other service, you
want to use network policies.
Network policies enable
you to ensure that--
let's say you have a
compromised front end service.
If you have a
compromised front end,
you might want to ensure
that something as critical
as your payments' backend
pods are not compromised.
So this way you can set
up network policy rules
for your services.
So, for example, in
this policy here, you
have ingress and
egress rules which
can work on the basis
of port selector labels
that you might have
on your services,
or you can work on the
basis of IP address rules.
So you can add address ranges
that have access or don't
have access to your services.
Network policy is enforced in
nearly real-time and scales
with your GKE
clusters seamlessly.
Ingress integrations-- now,
another very critical aspect
of your deployment is
ingress, and the communication
to the internet, and how
ingress actually sets up
your load balancer.
So we will talk about
a host of features
you have available to yourself
to integrate with ingress.
The first one is
Identity-Aware Proxy.
You can enable your employees
to work from untrusted networks
without the need of a VPN.
And moreover, you can give
them more granular access
than an all-or-nothing
access, which
is typical of VPN connections.
Cloud Armor is our defense
against distributed
denial-of-service
attacks engine.
You definitely want to have
some sort of DDoS protection
built-in into your load balancer
or some sort of DDoS protection
enabled for your deployments to
prevent from all sorts of edge
attacks from malicious actors.
Multiple TLS
certificate support--
so this is to enable
multiple SSL certificates
or multiple TLS certificates
for your deployments,
for every single
domain that you own.
So the first one,
Identity-Aware Proxy,
which enables you
IAM-based access
control on per
application basis.
Identity-Aware Proxy acts as
a central authorization layer
for all your applications.
And you can control
who gets access
on an application-level basis
to which all internal apps
you might have,
instead of relying
on network level
firewalls or VPN,
as I had mentioned earlier.
You see on the slide here how
to actually integrate with IAP.
So the first thing you define
is a BackendConfig object.
We introduced this
concept of a BackendConfig
object so that we could have
more GCP-specific annotations
for your GKE clusters.
The first thing you do is
define the BackendConfig object.
And then within the spec,
you set your IP settings.
The actual client, you
have to go ahead and create
as part of your IAP setup flow.
And then you just come back
here and add your secret name,
once you generate
the secret, as well.
And then once you've created
your BackendConfig object,
you go back to your
service definition
and you actually add a
link within annotations
for the service to your
BackendConfig object,
as mentioned here.
As I mentioned, IAP
performs authentication
and authorization on
per application level.
And this helps you basically
let your employees work
from anywhere on
untrusted networks.
Cloud Armor-- this is our
DDoS protection engine.
Besides DDoS attacks, it
has protections built-in
against a host of
different attacks,
such as SQL injection,
XSS attacks.
Currently it supports IP
blacklist and whitelist,
and also it has a
custom rules language
which you can use to
have custom rules set up
for your applications.
If you look here, you basically
have to set up, again,
in a very similar way to IAP.
You setup a
BackendConfig object,
and you define your security
policy within your spec.
The security policy
that you define here,
most of the
configuration is actually
a part of your regular
Cloud Armor setup.
And what you define
here is only the linkage
between the name of
your security policy
that you defined in
your Cloud Armor setup.
And similarly, once you define
your BackendConfig object,
you have to add a link back
to your service definition.
And this was done on
purpose, because we
wanted to simplify configuration
for your Cloud Armor security
policies and have them be done
in one single place with Cloud
Armor, and then just add
linkages wherever possible.
Visibility-- so one of
the most important things
when we talk about
network security
is being able to see what
is going on in your network
and let you know if there's any
malicious actors trying to gain
advantage of your network.
So one of the most important
things that we have for you
would be VPC Flow
Logs that can actually
give you raw logs of all the
flows within your network.
VPC Flow Logs are aggregated
every five seconds,
or nearly real-time, and they
are not agent-based for GKE.
VPC Flow Logs, moreover,
cover all the flow
within your network, whether
it's to or from the internet,
whether it's between
services in your VPC,
whether it's to manage
services, or whether it's
from your on-premises.
Moreover, it includes
both egress and ingress.
And it can be enabled at
the granularity of a subnet.
It also covers TCP-UDP flows.
And it also covers a host of
features like Shared VPC, VPC
Peering, et cetera.
A typical flow log record
includes bytes, inferred RTTs.
Moreover, it has
several annotations that
would be very useful, such
as VPC annotations, which
instance, which
subnetwork, et cetera,
and which region, which zone,
and other Geo annotations.
It can be used for security
analysis, network forensics.
Moreover, you can also
export the raw VPC Flow
Logs in a secure manner using
things like Cloud Pub/Sub
to Stackdriver Logging, or
BigQuery, or any other engine
of your choosing to visualize
them and track them.
So here we see how to
actually enable VPC Flow Logs.
As you can see, when you're
trying to create a subnet
or when you're trying to edit
a subnet within a VPC network,
you get the option of
turning on VPC Flow Logs.
So now we move into the demo.
So I think I mentioned
earlier, while introducing
Shared VPC, that what is
typical of organizations
is you have infra
or platform teams,
and then you have app teams.
And the app teams
are the ones that
actually create an application
that talks to your users
over the internet.
And the infra team
is the bottom there.
It would set up
things like firewalls,
or permissions, et cetera.
So typically, what you
want is the apps team
to create clusters, such that
they can talk to the internet
or just be able to
manage those clusters,
and the infra to set
up all those firewalls
and other rules.
So here, my setup would
include an organization
which has a host project
called infra-team and a service
project called apps-team.
The host project has a shared
VPC network called shared-net,
and it has one subnet
called apps-tier.
So the way I set
up my project here
is my clusters for apps-team
would be within the subnetwork
apps-tier.
And my host project
has already set up
firewalls and
everything else for me
to be able to communicate
over the internet.
Let's see now.
So here you see details
about the Shared VPC
network in infra-team project.
So these are my shared
subnets and permissions.
And as you can see
here, basically,
a host of service projects
have computer.network
user permissions.
And these are the only
permissions that they have,
which means my service
projects in my service
project robot
accounts can actually
use my apps-tier subnet without
needing to have edit or modify
permissions.
You can see here that
the only projects
I've attached to my account
are my apps-team projects.
Now, let's move on
to actually calling.
So if I actually move here--
so you see here now, that I
have to create two clusters
in my apps-team project.
One is a private
cluster which can
host a host of backend
services which don't need
to be on the public internet.
And my hello cluster has the
most amazing app ever built,
which is saying hello to
Google Cloud webinar viewers.
So now, I will just try to call
my application again and again.
And here you will see a
host of VPC Flow Logs.
So what I did earlier
was I had enabled
VPC Flow Log on the apps-tier
and my default subnet.
And how I actually get to
or export my VPC Flow Logs
is to through
Stackdriver logging.
So if I come here and I drill
down within my GCP subnetwork
and filter by only
VPC Flow Logs,
I get to all these
VPC Flow Logs.
Do note that every single one of
these records, even if I don't
make any requests, you will
actually see a lot flow
logs being generated.
Because we try to cover every
single flow in your network,
even if you're not getting
requests from the internet.
And if you try to drill down
here for a single request,
you'll actually see the
different annotations
that are there.
You see the VPC name, the
subnetwork name, the project
name.
You see the source
location, and you
see the connection information.
If you see, this is the
internal IP address of my node.
And similarly, that is also
an IP address of the master.
So you see, for
example, this record
is the communication between
the node and the master.
Similarly, you can use
this particular bar
to filter on the basis
of a specific pod.
Or if I'm making
requests from my host,
I can filter from my
IP address or something
to actually see communication
between the load
balancer and my servers.
So this way, you can get to
flow logs for your application.
Moving back--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So that
was an awesome demo, Manjot.
So today, hopefully
you learned a lot
about container network security
and some of the controls
that we have on GKE to help
you secure your network.
But talking about
container security a bit
more broadly, why would
you start using containers
to help you achieve
better security,
and is that even possible?
Well, as we really mentioned,
containers are short-lived
and frequently redeployed.
So you can actually
be constantly
patching and updating
your environment.
You can apply a patch
in your registry
that then gets
gradually rolled out
as you would roll out any other
change in your environment.
That leads to a
very different model
for how you manage patching,
rather than having maintenance
downtime and
windows in which you
have to do that kind of work.
Containers are
immutable, so you can
ensure that your
environment doesn't change.
What that means is that
if a container does change
production you know
something's gone wrong,
and you can then kill that
container and redeploy as
needed.
It also means that you have
content addressability,
so you know exactly what's been
deployed in your environment.
And then if something
does change--
if there's new
vulnerability discovered,
for example-- you
can compare what
you deployed to
the vulnerability,
rather than having to
scan your production
environment directly.
That saves you a lot of time.
With the control plane
being managed in a container
orchestration system,
you can actually
secure the communications
that happen
between the control
plane in the services
and between your services.
So in addition to what Manjot
was just describing today,
around using network policy,
using VPC Flow Logs, et cetera,
how your control plane-to-node
communication happens
is secured and can use
encryption authentication,
et cetera.
And then, lastly, in terms
of container security
here, good security defaults
are one-line changes.
You can follow a lot
of best practices
by implementing Linux changes.
Things like enabling seccomp,
or in GKE turning on master
authorized networks.
It's a single change
for you and your team
to get that best practice.
Now, what that means overall
is that running containers
allows you to adopt
a fundamentally
different security model.
You are constantly patching.
You are constantly redeploying.
It is that kind of DevSecOps
or continuous security
that people talk about.
But you don't necessarily
lose a lot of the control
you have from before.
They're just different from
how you were doing it with VMs.
Now, on GKE specifically,
obviously, we
think we have great security
and great network security here.
So GKE provides best practices
with security by default.
There's always going be app
level hardening for you to do,
but more and more things are
being built into the platform
by default. You can check
out our hardening guide
online for what
we'd recommend you
do beyond what's already there.
Things like network policy being
shipped as part of GKE core
has been true for
several versions now.
The Kubernetes
dashboard is disabled--
lots of other security
features built-in.
GKE patches you did the
latest version automatically.
So the control plane is patched
for you by our SRE team,
and then nodes you
can set to autoupgrade
to get patches as well.
This keeps you up-to-date
with not only the latest
feature releases,
including new security
features the new
networking features,
but latest security patches.
If you've been
following the news,
we had a major
security vulnerability
that was announced yesterday.
It's already patched in GKE.
We had one a few weeks ago
that affected network policy.
It's already patched in GKE.
So you get that benefit by
having a managed solution.
And GKE provides the best of
Google Cloud Security features.
So there are integrations with
things like IAM audit logging,
but also with Shared
VPC, with VPC Flow Logs,
with IAP, with lots
of other things
that you might want to use to
improve your overall security
and network security story.
There's a few links for you
here to learn a little bit more,
including an overview of
our network for containers
and container security.
But please stay
tuned for a live Q&A,
and we'll be back in
less than a minute.
Awesome.
We're back with the
questions from the audience.
So, Manjot, the
first one here, does
network policy work to
restrict pod to pod traffic
within a node?
MANJOT PAHWA: So you so you
can setup network policy
to restrict which
services can talk to which
other services on the
basis of, as I said,
enabled app selectors
or IP addresses.
And if that
condition holds true,
then you can restrict
port-to-port traffic,
whether it's within a
node or between nodes.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Do I
need to do anything special
to set it up between nodes,
or does it just kind of work?
MANJOT PAHWA: It will just
work through the policy agent.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: OK.
The next question
here, do I need
to use master
authorized networks
to use private clusters?
MANJOT PAHWA: The answer is no.
You can definitely use
master authorized network
in isolation, with or without
using private clusters.
We highly recommend using
master authorized networks
with private clusters.
In fact, another
recommendation I will make
is, you should probably
think of making
private clusters the default
for all your clusters,
unless internet
access is required.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
That's a good idea.
The next one, do
private clusters
have private IP addresses
for the control plane?
MANJOT PAHWA: So
there is a private IP
address and a public IP
address both on the master.
The private IP address,
as I mentioned,
is used to communicate
privately with the nodes.
But there is a public IP
address, which we manage.
And that we use for our internal
management purposes currently.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: How does
Istio work with Kubernetes,
and what does it protect?
MANJOT PAHWA: Istio definitely
adds a few more features
on top of Kubernetes for more
defense, in-depth protection.
For example, one of the
things that Istio offers
is mutual TLS between services.
So your services can actually
authenticate and authorize
while communicating
with other services.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So
Istio is for service
to service, but then not
for pod to pod, for example.
MANJOT PAHWA: Yes.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: OK.
And then, what's the
recommended configuration
if I want to peer my
on-prem network to GKE?
MANJOT PAHWA: So we have a
host of different options
under the Cloud Interconnect.
Depending on what kind
of reliability you want,
like how reliable you
want the connection to be
and things like
that, you can choose
a host of different
products under Cloud
Interconnect, such as VPN,
dedicated Interconnect,
et cetera.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
I would set that up
with a VPC or
something like that?
MANJOT PAHWA: Yes, yes.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: OK.
Cool.
So I think that's a wrap for us.
Please stay tuned for
the next session CETV,
Google Cloud Networking 103--
Securing your network.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]